مع اقتراب حلول الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع
الحرب اشتدت لغه التهديد والوعيد بين
روسيا والمعسكر الغربي الداعم لاوكرانيا
الرئيس الامريكي اختار وارسو المجاوره
لاوكرانيا ليبعث برسائله الى روسيا ويشدد
على دعمه المستمر في الحرب بايدن هدد
بوتين صراحه بدفع ثمن باهظ جراء الازمه
الحاليه في اوكرانيا بايدن ايضا لم يضيع
الفرصه دون الاشاده بحلف النيتو ومواقفه
الداعمه لاوكرانيا رئيس الامريكي الذي
زارا كييف قبل الحلول ببولندا بعث بتحيه
للشعب الاوكراني مشيدا بشجاعته كما عاد
للحديث عن اندلاع الحرب قبل عام واصفا هذه
الخطوه بالقرار الخاطئ
الرئيس بوتين اطلق دباباته لتجوب مناطق
مختلفه من اوكرانيا وكان مخطئا في هذا
القرار الشعب الاوكراني يتحلى بقدر كبير
من الشجاعه الناتو والدول الاوروبيه
اتحدوا في مواقفهم بدعم اوكرانيا واستطاعت
القوات الاوكرانيه ان تحرق الدبابات
الروسيه الناتو ولد من رحم الوحده
بايدن توجه بالكلام مباشره الى بوتين
واصفا اياه بالرجل البعيد عن المنطق كما
اكد عن قرب الاعلان عن حزمه عقوبات جديده
في حق روسيا هذا ولم يفوت الرئيس الامريكي
الفرصه دون الحديث عن حرب الطاقه حيث
اعتبر ان المعسكر الغربي نجح في تجاوز هذه
الازمه التي افتعلها بوتين على حد قوله
الولايات المتحده بحاجه الى بولندا
والنيتو بقدر حاجه النيتو الى الولايات
المتحده لانه لا توجد طريقه مغايره للعمل
في ظل توسع مسؤولياتنا وحاجاتنا لتعزيز
الامن في اوروبا الامر بهذه البساطه وهذه
الاهميه بل لربما هو اعظم تحالف في
التاريخ كله وليس المعاصر فقط وهنا وجب
التاكيد على دور الولايات المتحده
والتزامها الحقيقي وساجادل بان الناتو
اليوم في افضل احواله وكما قلت للرئيس
الاوكراني بالامس في كييف بان واجب الدعم
اتجاه اوكرانيا لن يتزعزع